bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
historia hoy abordaremos el pasado de
las tensiones y las guerras entre israel
y el grupo militante hamas
lo que comenzó en jerusalén con fuertes
enfrentamientos entre manifestantes
palestinos y la policía israelí en la
icónica explanada de las mezquitas
derivó en un fuego cruzado de cohetes
bombardeos aéreos y despliegue de
artillería entre hamás e israel una
violencia de este tipo en gasa no se
vivía desde 2014 año del más sangriento
conflicto entre ambos bandos en julio de
aquel año
israel estalló una guerra de 50 días que
justificó necesaria para detener el
lanzamiento de cohetes por parte de
hamás desde gaza según estimaciones de
la onu en la guerra de 2014 entre hamás
e israel murieron alrededor de 2.200
palestinos la mitad de ellos civiles del
lado israelí murieron 73 personas
incluidos 6 civiles la onu también cifró
en 171.000 el número de hogares
completamente devastados ya decenas de
miles de familias desprotegidas incluso
a una franja de gaza- completamente en
ruinas pero de dónde viene jamás el
grupo militante islámico que no cesa
lucha contra israel hamas es un grupo
cuyo origen se remonta a la primera
intifada corría el año de 1987 y el
sentimiento nacionalista palestino dio
origen a la famosa guerra de las piedras
miles de palestinos a punta de piedras y
palos se enfrentaron al poderoso
ejército israelí en su lucha contra la
ocupación de israel en los territorios
de cisjordania y la franja de gaza
aquella primera intifada duró largos
seis años y sólo terminó con los
acuerdos de oslo de 1993 un tratado de
paz firmado entre yaser arafat e isaac
rabín tras contabilizar la muerte de más
de 3100 palestinos y cerca de 130
israelíes pese a la paz lograda el grupo
jamás se había consolidado bajo una
carta fundacional en la cual quedó
establecido el no reconocimiento al
estado de israel y la lucha de su
soberanía en la región histórica de
palestina la segunda intifada estalló en
septiembre del año 2000 en jerusalén la
ciudad que permanece en disputa entre
islas
el ies y palestinos pues ambos la
consideran la capital de sus estados
justamente en las inmediaciones de la
mezquita de al-aqsa el lugar más sagrado
de los musulmanes en jerusalén se
apareció el por entonces líder israelí
ariel sharon la provocación que
sintieron los fieles musulmanes por la
visita de sharon los llevó nuevamente a
enfrentarse a las fuerzas israelíes a
punta de piedra sin importar que durante
cinco años murieran alrededor de 5.000
palestinos en su mayoría civiles del
lado israelí murieron cerca de 1000
personas durante los cinco años de la
segunda intifada ocurrieron varios
hechos interesantes de una parte los
ataques suicidas de militantes de hamas
fueron vistos en la población palestina
como un mecanismo efectivo contra la
ocupación de israel de otra parte en
marzo de 2004 murió el líder de hamás su
fundador y líder espiritual el jeque
ahmed yasín y finalmente unos meses más
tarde con la muerte de yaser arafat a
sus 75 años el por entonces principal
líder
y uno de los fundadores de fatá el
camino político de hamás quedó en
situación favorable para ganar las
elecciones palestinas de 2006 otro de
los aspectos que aventajó a hamás en
popularidad fue su trabajo social en
clínicas y hospitales para salvaguardar
a las víctimas palestinas que dejaban la
segunda intifada en cambio los
palestinos miraron con recelo a pata el
movimiento a la cabeza de la autoridad
nacional palestina
por entonces señalados de actos de
corrupción e ineficacia política el
triunfo de hamas sobre falta en las
elecciones legislativas de 2006
desencadenó una crisis política que a su
vez quebró cualquier alianza de las dos
facciones palestinas así el panorama
jamás se quedó con la jurisdicción de la
franja de gaza mientras que fatal se
ocupó del control de cisjordania con
hamás a cargo de gaza y habiendo sido
denominado organización terrorista por
varias naciones incluyendo a israel eeuu
y la unión europea los enfrentamientos
en la frontera de gaza con israel no se
hicieron esperar el primer gran
conflicto
ocurrió entre diciembre de 2008 y enero
de 2009 su detonante fue el lanzamiento
de cohetes de hamas como respuesta al
desabastecimiento sufrido por el bloqueo
israelí en 2012 hubo otro conflicto por
un aumento de las tensiones en gasa de
corta duración pero que dejó 170
palestinos muertos así las cuentas los
conflictos directos entre hamás e israel
han ocurrido sin contar las intifadas en
el año 2008 en el 2012 el 2014 y ahora
en el 2021 si bien eeuu y la unión
europea han reivindicado la defensa
legítima de israel de los territorios
que le fueron asignados por la onu en
1948 año de la creación de su estado las
organizaciones de derechos humanos
internacionales han denunciado la
desproporción con que israel contraataca
a sus enemigos árabes y ejemplo de ellos
son la cantidad exagerada de muertos
civiles del lado palestino la
destrucción masiva de sus ciudades y los
territorios anexados ilegalmente en la
guerra de los seis días
del lado de los palestinos hamas funge
como el ala extremista que dice no ceder
ante israel hasta tanto no recuperar los
territorios ocupados en especial
jerusalén del este la considerada por
los palestinos capital de su futuro
estado y que desde 1967 permanece en
control absoluto de israel un conflicto
que aparentemente no tiene fin así
concluimos soy andrés suárez jaramillo
gracias por compartir y comentar estas
historias que las encuentran en los
programas de france 24 punto com